There are 1000s of videos on YouTube of people
whispering, eating, tapping on surfaces -- all
with the goal of giving you....BRAIN TINGLES.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
I have a weird confession for you.
Since I was a little kid, I've had this strong
sensation from certain peoples' voices.
Most often the person is soft spoken, maybe
a little breathy, and the way they pronounce
certain sounds like "k", "d", and "t" is sort
of.......crisp sounding?
Bob Ross would be the most well known one.
I also have the reaction from sounds -- like
when someone is rummaging through makeup or
crinkling plastic baggies.
These are some of MY triggers, but there are
lots out there: the sound of someone writing,
polishing shoes, or brushing hair.
The sensation is incredibly challenging to
describe -- like a tingling in my head and
scalp, but it's not a PHYSICAL tingling.
Some people call it a "braingasm".
The sounds can almost instantly make me relax
and my mind zone out.
It's hypnotic and it's very euphoric -- but
not in a sexual way.
It's not a fetish, and it's not erotic.
Common misunderstanding.
The pleasant tingling sensation has recently
been widely referred to as "ASMR", or Autonomous
Sensory Meridian Response.
The subreddit for ASMR now boasts over 60,000
regular members who all experience the same
response.
Other internet groups before Reddit referred
to it as "The Unnamed Sensation".
It's all veeeeery mysterious.
What's going on with this strange sensation?
Sadly, only ONE scientist has formally studied
ASMR - at least as identified by that name.
Someone else may have studied it but the name
of the phenomenon is unknown and therefore
unsearchable.
The scientist at Dartmouth who did study it
looked at fMRI scans of people experiencing
an ASMR episode - which could be very telling
about what's going on in the brain....buuuut
the publication of his results are still in
process.
There have been many theories posed, however.
One comes from ethnobotanists -- that ASMR
could be the conscious experience of serotonin
release.
From neurologists is the theory that ASMR
is a type of muted seizure.
I didn't know this, but apparently seizures
can be quite pleasurable and triggered by
simple sounds like this.
Another theory posed by Dr. Steven Novella,
a neurologist at Yale, is that these sounds
are activating a pleasure response, which
is an evolutionary response that occurs when
we do things that increase our probability
of survival.
Dr. Novella also theorized that it's possible
that those with ASMR have a particular neural
hard wiring that amplifies the pleasure they
get from things that are normally quietly
satisfying.
There's a lot we don't know, but what we do
know is that this response is uncommon but
still widely experienced.
We also know that the response is not the
same as tinglies you might get while listening
to music, which can cause physical effects
like goosebumps.
Similarly, it's not the same effect as binaural
sounds either.
So, do any of you experience ASMR?
If you don't, how much of a weirdo do I sound
like right now? :P
Let me know down below and check out our new
Testtube app so you can get updates on the
go.
Thanks for joining me, I'll cya next time.